we're trying to get a comment
another twist now in the case against an
alleged child rapist and cult leader the
head of a group aimed at fighting human
trafficking is one of Nathan chasing
horses allies eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy is
uncovering more and more as she
continues her coverage
can you talk to us
we're trying to get a comment this is
Jennifer McQuaid a supporter of Nathan
chasing horse an accused child rapist
facing sex trafficking and sexual
assault charges the 8 news now
investigators have uncovered McQuaid has
been heading a program at the Salvation
Army to combat human trafficking they
can be inspired to know that healing is
possible here she is speaking to 8 news
now about the program last month and
while promoting a program to help
survivors in videos photos and posts on
social media McQuaid is seen with
members of chasing horses alleged cult
the circle sources say one of her
daughters is one of chasing horses wives
in North Las Vegas Justice Court
Wednesday public defender Christy
Holston arguing against the two million
dollar bill prosecutors asked for
requesting for chasing horse to be
allowed to live with a family member the
family member actually works for an
organization that fights that's human
trafficking his family member knowing
the accusations have been you know
widely reported we've learned she's
referring to mcquate We visited her
North Las Vegas home where chasing horse
would live while wearing a GPS bracelet
but only if he posts bail which Pro tem
judge Craig Newman said at three hundred
thousand dollars Lynn Cooper heads the
homeowners association in the
neighborhood I don't understand the
system and how they work for the
criminals and we calculated just 0.2
miles away from that house where Nathan
chasing horse could live if he's
released from custody is Eva G Simmons
Elementary School we can't have him stay
there we tried reaching Jennifer McQuaid
hi Jennifer this is Vanessa Murphy on
Wednesday she was still on the voicemail
for the Salvation Army program hello
you've reached Jennifer McQuaid Seeds of
Hope anti-human trafficking coordinator
after we tried reaching the Salvation
Army multiple times could you please
call me on Thursday we showed up at
their Las Vegas headquarters hi hi I
tried to call you yeah I got I got you
okay Scott Johnson out of our
headquarters is handling all media
inquiries and I'm happy to give you his
email
I've emailed him I've called him I
called his office I called his cell
phone we need an answer was she working
with human trafficking survivors Scott
Johnson is handling all of our media
inquiry does she still work here he's
handling all media inquiries can you
talk to us and then outside we noticed
McQuade in the vehicle next to us we're
trying to get a comment later that
afternoon the Salvation Army's Scott
Johnson sent this email stating McQuaid
is now on a leave of absence but he
wouldn't specify when that began Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now